Film Courage: Fatih, I would love to hear
your process for making the playlist using
Queens of the Stone Age for [IN THE FADE’s
protagonist] Katja and how you sort of developed
her emotions within their songs?
Fatih Akin: Finding the right music in the
early stage is always very important for me
that I have an access to my own material and
emotional access because music is all about
emotions.
And I was looking for what is the right tone
for this?
And the tone it has to be something which
is melancholic and aggressive at the same
time.
And I was like “Okay, that’s Queen’s
music!”
So I made up this list of certain songs of
all the Queens of the Stone Age albums and
I gave the playlist to Diane.
It was an instinctive thought you know of
songs and Diane immediately responded to it,
very positively.
She wasn’t like “I hate the music.”
You know, she was not like that at all.
She said it felt right.
So I get in touch with Josh Homme [frontman
of Queens of the Stone Age].
And I told him “Hey, I’m this filmmaker
from Germany and I’m doing this film.
And it’s a bit tiny and it’s about this
and that.”
And he said “Can you send me the film?”
So I sent him the very rough cut.
He immediately liked the film a lot and he
asked me “Does the score have to be rock?”
And I said “Josh, do whatever you feel is
right.”
And he did it and I think he made the perfect
soundtrack for it.
Film Courage: Absolutely.
[Diane] On a film set, is a director always
right?
Diane Kruger: Uh, 98 percent, yes.
Film Courage: What about the other 2 percent?
Diane Kruger: The other 2 percent I feel like
sometimes an actor has an instinct and that
goes against the instinct of the director
and when you propose it, it turns out sometimes
the actor is right, you know?
But I would always, always first go with the
director’s instinct and then you can just
sort of fine tune it, maybe?
Film Courage: Fatih, do you have any instances
where there was a scene and Diane suggested
one other way and how it worked?
I mean are you sort of married to one idea
or are you very fluid in terms of how you
approach a filming day?
Fatih Akin: I work fluidly.
I work very close with my actors and I don’t
know everything, you know?
It’s like…I don’t have the impression
that it’s 98 percent.
I think it’s less, you know?
I don’t mean it as a humble thing, I mean
it as it is.
For me working on the set, I like every aspect
of it.
I like the technical aspect, I like the camera,
I like the writing, I like the breaks to do
the food.
But what I like the most on set to work on
is with the actors.
That’s how everything starts for me.
That’s the thing that interests me the most.
And here I really had an exchange that I came
up with half an idea and Diane has half an
idea and together we make one idea out of
it, which is right.
In the very last shot of the trial of the
film where there is this [camera] trekking
back and zooming in scene, I had the idea
that Diane has to act differently than what
she is doing in the film.
Because the technical element of that shot
was so difficult.
I mean 7 or 8 takes and maybe Diane was tired
of that emotion?
I don’t know, I don’t remember?
But all she felt like was that it doesn’t
feel right.
She said that after the 12th or 13th takes,
she said “Can I suggest something?
I would like to do it differently.
I would like to do nothing.”
And I was like “Yeah, go ahead.”
And she made it and first of all, that was
the best take in terms of technically.
And you know it was like a spiritual thing.
It was like that was right because she gave
the right emotion, the camera filmed it in
the right way.
I believe in these things, you know?
I saw her attitude, her idea and I used it
for the whole last part of the film (what
she’d given in there).
So it was more than 98 percent, I tell you.
I mean less, sorry!
It was less than 98 percent.
Film Courage: Even under ideal circumstances
everyone has days where even if they love
a project, it gets to be a lot.
You know, different things happen, life happens.
So what keeps you going with a project even
when it seems like the Universe is sort of
conspiring against you, which tends to happen
even with something that you love?
What keeps you going with a project?
Even when it seems like there are all of these
things in your way and you stay with it?
Fatih Akin: The tiny little voice in your
ear.
It really is there and everybody can say “I
don’t like the screenplay and I don’t
think it’s bankable.
I don’t think anybody will see it.”
I hear these things, especially from this
film, based on that screenplay.
I heard that a lot from very close people
around me.
But there’s an inner voice when those people
cannot touch this voice, then you know it’s
right and then you go on.
Sometimes if they can touch this voice, they
may be right and you start to question it.
Diane Kruger: Well, once you are committed
to a project, you’re sort of in it.
There’s no way of having a bad day.
I think at least the times when I’ve been
on a film set and I felt like the movie is
not going to be great or the director is not
all that great or I don’t know…whatever
you can feel in that moment, it’s your duty
to try and elevate it as much as you can.
There’s never been a moment in my life on
the set where I felt like giving up.
You always try and it doesn’t always work
out.
We all know that some movies come out better
than others.
But you have to try, like sometimes even harder
because of it.